okay Leute es gibt eine relativ neue und
sehr zukunftsträchtige Art nachhaltig
Energie zu gewinnen die kaum einer kennt
und mit der kaum einer rechnet eine
Energiequelle die aus der Natur kommt
sogar CO2 einspeichern kann keine
Flächen verbraucht relativ günstig sein
soll und sowohl Kraftstoff für Autos und
Flugzeuge sein kann aber auch
gleichzeitig essbar ist die Rede ist von
alten doch bei all diesen ganz krassen
mega Vorteilen warum redet dann keiner
davon und wie realistisch ist das ganze
wirklich wird es wirklich bald
eigenkraftstoff in Deutschland geben um
all das zu beantworten bin ich einfach
mal dahin geflogen wo dieser Kraftstoff
unter anderem hergestellt wird nach
Indien und da habe ich mit einem Team
gesprochen das mir erlaubt hat diesen
Kraftstoff genauer unter die Lupe zu
nehmen herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen Video auf Dr Watson
übrigens wenn ihr zu den vielen Menschen
zählt die sich für 204 vorgenommen haben
mehr für die Natur zu tun dann habe ich
am Ende des Videos noch eine Kleinigkeit
für euch den ersten 200 von euch schenke
ich nämlich einen Monat Naturschutz bei
der Organisation Planet wild und zwar in
eurem Namen bleibt also auf jeden Fall
bis zum Schluss dran die Menschheit
braucht immer mehr Energie dafür wurden
in den letzten Jahrzehnten vor allem
Erdöl Kohle und Gas genutzt und die
Konsequenzen daraus kennen wir alle um
den steigenden Energiebedarf nachhaltig
zu stillen wurden schon viele
verschiedene erneuerbare Energiequellen
gefunden besonders für Wärme und
Stromerzeugung gibt es inzwischen schon
sehr viele Lösungen allerdings sieht das
Ganze bei den Kraftstoff die vor allem
im Transportsektor eine Rolle spielen
noch etwas anders aus hier gibt es noch
immer keine wirklich guten Alternativen
zu Erdöl und nicht jedes Transportmittel
kann auf E-Mobilität umsteigen jedoch
trägt gerade der Transportsektor zu
einem erheblichen Anteil zum
Energieverbrauch bei 2021 hat der
Verkehr durch die Verbrennung von
Kraftstoffen alleine in der EU rund 740
Millionen Tonnen kohlendiooxid
ausgestoßen das entspricht ungefähr 21%
aller Emissionen der EU aus diesem Jahr
Alternativen bieten hier Biokraftstoffe
oder auch Wasserstoff doch auch die
haben leider ihre Nachteile schaut euch
dazu gerne mal unser Video über
Wasserstoffautos an aber long story
short auch bei den herkömmlichen
Biokraftstoffen ist unter anderem der
Flächenverbrauch ein großes Problem für
die Herstellung mancher Biokraftstoffe
werden Nahrungs und Futterpflanzen wie
Mais Getreide Raps Palm oder Sojaöl
genutzt das nennt man dann Kraftstoffe
der ersten Generation und diese Pflanzen
müssen irgendwo pepflanzt werden und
stehen so auch in Konkurrenz zu unseren
Nahrungsmitteln es braucht also weitere
Lösungen um wirklich nachhaltige
Kraftstoffe herzustellen und hier gibt
es inzwischen eine sehr
vielversprechende Lösung und das sind
Algen Algen zählen zu den
Biokraftstoffen der sogenannten dritten
Generation und sollen die perfekte
erneuerbare Ressource zur Herstellung
von Biokraftstoffen sein das liegt vor
allem daran dass Algen zum einen sehr
schnell wachsende Organismen sind und
zum anderen außer Licht und Nährstoffen
vor allem Kohlenstoffdioxid zieht nicht
viel mehr brauchen um daraus dann
Biomasse erzeugen zu können aber wie gut
sind eigenkraftstoffe wirklich könnte
das unsere Zukunft sein um diese Frage
zu beantworten habe ich ein Institut auf
der anderen Seite der Welt besucht und
zwar Teri in Mumbai Indien und ja es mag
sehr komisch wirken dass ich für ein
nachhaltiges Projekt nach Indien Fliege
aber ich war sowieso schon für ein ganz
anderes Projekt in Indien unterwegs und
da hat sich das einfach super
kombinieren lassen auch mal bei diesem
Projekt vorbeizuschauen und natürlich
ist das hier auch keine Werbung
um algenkraftstoff effizient
herzustellen braucht es vor allem Wärme
und viel Sonnenlicht und das bietet
Indien anders als Deutschland gesprochen
habe ich dort mit einem der forschenden
der mir auch die Anlage gezeigt hat
diese Anlage ist ein Test aber trotzdem
hat sie bereits ein Fassungsvermögen von
100.000 l okay aber erstmal von vorne
was sind genau überhaupt Algen und warum
kommen Sie gerade zuur Herstellung von
Kraftstoff in Frage Algen sind im Wasser
lebende Organismen die Fotosynthese
betreiben das heißt dass sie nicht nur
selber kein CO2 herstellen sondern sogar
CO2 speichern und in Sauerstoff
umwandeln können die Hauptbestandteile
von Algen sind Kohlenhydrate Proteine
und Lipide also natürliche Öle und
gerade das Öl ist in großen Mengen
vorhanden viel mehr als in anderen
Pflanzen das macht Algen zu einem
perfekten Ausgangsmaterial für die
Erzeugung von
Biokraftstoffen jeder Hektar Algen soll
einen ölertrag von mehr als 47 000 l
Kraftstoff erbringen z Vergleich Palmöl
bringt als Biokraftstoff pro Hektar nur
etwa 4500 l Öl und Soja sogar nur um die
378 l unterschieden werden Algen
zwischen Makro und Mikroalgen als
Rohstoff für die Kraftstofferzeugung
können prinzipiell beide Algenarten
verwendet werden besser geeignet sind
jedoch die Mikroalgen diese haben eine
schnellere Wachstumsrate und können das
ganze Jahr über geerntet werden außerdem
können Sie überall gezüchtet werden so
auch auf marginalem Land also Land das
durch unfruchtbare Böden sowieso nicht
für die Landwirtschaft nutzbar wäre ein
weiterer Vorteil von Algen ist dass bei
der Herstellung der aligenkraftstoffe
zusätzlich Nebenprodukte anfallen da für
den Kraftstoff nur die Lipide gebraucht
werden bleiben die in der Alge
enthaltenen Kohlenhydrate und Proteine
übrig aus denen sich dann z.B sehr
hochwertiges Tierfutter Dünger
biologisch abbaubares Plastik oder auch
Menschennahrung herstellen lassen es
würden sogar so viele Nebenprodukte
entstehen dass allein diese reichen
würden um global alle Tiere in der
Tierproduktion zu ernähren wow in der
Praxis heißt das in Zukunft müsste z.B
kein Regenwald mehr für den Anbau von
Soja gerodet werden noch sinnvoller wäre
es jedoch die
Algenbiomasse direkt als Ernährung für
den Menschen zu nutzen die enthaltenen
Nährstoffe sind sehr hochwertig und
durch die vielen Antioxidanzien sogar
auch noch sehr gesundheitsfördernd damit
könnte sich auch das Problem der
Lebensmittelsicherheit lösen und als
wäre das nicht schon alles genug die
Herstellung des eigenkraftstoffes
verbraucht anders als bei den sonstigen
Biokraftstoffen kein Trinkwasser die
Herstellung benötigt lediglich mehr
Wasser von dem wir zum Glück mehr als
genug haben noch dazu besitzen Algen die
Fähigkeit Wasser reinigen zu können so
können Algen genutzt werden um
verunreinigtes Wasser z.B industrielles
Abwasser zu säubern und gleichzeitig
dabei sauberes Benzin zu produzieren und
jetzt kommt das was ich echt am
krassesten finde algentreibstoff soll
laut dem Team in Indien in den nächsten
Jahren mit literpreisen von 60 Cent
möglich werden und das ist auch die
Meinung von anderen unabhängigen
Experten mit denen wir gesprochen haben
unter 1 € pro Liter Biokraftstoff ist
definitiv realisierbar damit wäre der
algenkraftstoff deutlich günstiger als
die aktuellen Benzinpreise von ca 1,70 €
und umso mehr investiert und in Massen
produziert wird desto billiger wird es
okay Algen sind eine CO2 einspeichernde
schnell nachwachsende erneuerbare
Ressource die nur sonst eh unbrauchbare
Landflächen verbraucht kein Trinkwasser
verschwendet sogar Wasser reinigt noch
dazu den Regenwald schützen könnte und
auch noch für eine weltweite
Ernährungssicherheit sorgen kann holy
Shit aber wenn Algen doch so eine super
geile mega krasse Ressource sind die für
alles eine Lösung ist warum ist sie dann
noch nicht überall warum investiert
nicht die ganze Welt da rein okay zu
allererst wirklich Sinn ergibt der
eigenkraftstoff primär leider nur bei
Flugzeugen und eventuell noch dem
Schiffsverkehr für Autos sieht das
anders aus denn hier ist die
Elektromobilität einfach die
effizienteste Möglichkeit sich
vorzubewegen allein in dem Hinblick dass
die Produktion des algenkraftstoffes
selber sehr viel Strom verbraucht den
man ja auch einfach direkt in ein E-Auto
packen könnte allerdings kann es für
Flugzeuge eine wirklich
vielversprechende Lösung sein da hier
Batterien nicht in Frage kommen und der
eigenkraftstoff tatsächlich CO2 neutral
und sogar CO2 negativ sein kann hier
kommt es darauf an wie der
Herstellungsprozess aussieht da dieser
sehr energiebedürftig ist die größten
Einflüsse auf die Umwelt Bilanz haben
der verwendete Dünger und die
Elektrizität allerdings gibt es für
beides bereits jetzt schon gute
technologische Lösungen sodass die
Kraftstoffe wirklich CO2 negativ sein
können warum der eigenkraftstoff
trotzdem noch nicht großflächig auf dem
Markt für das Fliegen genutzt wird hat
primär einen Grund Geld zum einen
bleiben fossile Kraftstoffe bis heute
leider unschlagbar günstig und machen so
einen Wettbewerb für generell alle
nachhaltigen Ressourcen extrem schwierig
dass das so ist liegt zwar nur daran
dass der Preis von fossilen
Energieträgern nicht die Umweltkosten
beinhaltet und so nicht wirklich den
tatsächlichen Preis widerspiegelt aber
so funktioniert nun mal leider unser
Wirtschaftssystem zum anderen werden
algenkraftstoffe bis jetzt nur in sehr
kleinen Mengen und hauptsächlich zu
Forschungszwecken gewonnen das macht vor
allem die Abschätzung der möglichen
erzeugbaren Mengen sehr schwierig da
diese nur auf Hochrechnungen beruhen die
sich nicht unbedingt auf industrielle
Großproduktionen übertragen lassen
können wirtschaftlich rentabel wird der
Kraftstoff aber erst bei solch einer
großflächigen massenproduk Option und um
diese zu starten muss zu Beginn vor
allem viel Geld investiert werden
Unternehmen müssen sich erst einmal
komplett neu aufstellen noch dazu sind
die neuen Technologien sehr teuer und
der Prozess verbraucht viel Energie die
für eine positive Umweltbilanz aus
erneuerbaren Quellen stammen muss das
alles verursacht immense Kosten und
stellt ein hohes Risiko dar das für ein
Unternehmen alleine viel zu groß wäre
deswegen muss laut den Experten mit
denen wir gesprochen haben Unterstützung
vom Staat mit Hilfe von Steuergeldern
erfolgen
okay sind eigen der Kraftstoff der
Zukunft der eigenkraftstoff bietet ultra
viele Lösungen und könnte so tatsächlich
ein wichtiger Baustein für eine
nachhaltigere Zukunft sein eine Zukunft
weg von fossilen Kraftstoffen aber er
ist eben auch nur ein Baustein von
vielen und nicht die eine Superlösung
nach der wir nichts anderes mehr tun
müssen eigen werden uns vielleicht bald
schon helfen können die Emissionen im
Flugsektor zu reduzieren was schon mal
eine riesige Sache wäre hier auch einer
Appell an die Politik bei solchen
Innovationen für die richtige
Unterstützung zu sorgen nichtsdestotrotz
tanken werdet ihr ihn persönlich
wahrscheinlich nie und generell bleibt
es trotz solcher guter Lösungen an
erneuerbaren Energien und Innovationen
leider unausweichlich dass wir unseren
Energiekonsum trotzdem zusätzlich
reduzieren müssen da führt leider so
oder so kein Weg in der Zukunft dran
vorbei und auch e-fuels sind leider
keine Alternative zur E-Mobilität warum
das so ist das erklären wir euch in
diesem Video hier und bevor jetzt ins
neue Jahr startet hätte ich noch eine
wichtige Sache laut diversen Umfragen
ist nämlich ein sehr häufig vorkommender
jahresvorsatz im nächsten Jahr mehr für
die Natur zu tun und aus diesem Grund
möchte ich euch ein Team aus Berlin
vorstellen das sich einer echt wichtigen
Sache verschrieben hat und auf eure
Unterstützung angewiesen ist Planet wild
ist eine Naturschutzorganisation die
jeden Monat ein großes Projekt
durchführt um unseren Planeten zu
schützen und die Schäden zu beheben die
die Menschen der Natur zufügen und ihre
Projekte sind auf die monatlichen
Beiträge einer Community angewiesen die
die Erhaltung unserer Ökosysteme
unterstützen möchte wenn ihr also schon
länger den Wunsch hattet etwas für die
Erhaltung der Natur zu tun dann ist die
Unterstützung einer Organisation wie
Planet wild schon ein sehr sehr guter
Anfang bei Planet wild gefällt mir
außerdem besonders gut dass Sie zu jedem
ihrer Projekte ein Youtube Video machen
in dem man mit eigenen Augen sehen kann
was die Community gemeinsam bewirkt wenn
ihr also jetzt ein Teil dieser Community
werden wollt dann habe ich noch ein
besonderes Angebot für euch für die
ersten 200 Leute die sich über den Link
in der Videobeschreibung bei Plan wild
anmelden werde ich den ersten Monat
übernehmen und ihr könnt natürlich auch
jeden Monat kündigen und die
Mitgliedschaft pausieren wenn ihr das
wollt ansonsten guten Rutsch frohes
neues Jahr und bleibt neugierig euer
Cedric